on the draw and we are underway in Australia
Drew Dowdy on a shoot in Mikey Anderson on the
left-wing side has shot sails wide to the net head
coach of the coyotes he said he talked to them at
the point of the trade and said we want you back
Kings with a man Advantage for another 50
seconds Byfield with a shot Off The Stick of
stature and wide Kings work it out to the right
Point battling doting is there with lizotte but
the coyotes away with it Kent clear it and
a chance on the right side by Trevor Lewis
his kick down Lewis again down low he's at
the goal line he centers deflects in save
Lewis the wrap around bid still loose to the
side of the net and covered by Conor Ingram
everybody not much of ice pressure by the Kings
but now a turnover by jersey fialo with it hands
it off Deborah called back right side and a shot
save is made Dubois Rod then we get a whistle the
goaltenders equipment he lost his helmet Matthias
Michelli cost ice pass tip he gets it back
Micelli looking shooting save Coplay well
the battle by the coyotes to get the shot
open up the lane was there majelli finds a
way to assisted Matthias Michelli last year
and here's a turnover and a chance in front a
give and go but the return never got to Zucker
Matt Roy the vice pressured
by Cooley and Roy has to
carry the pass and it goes all the way down
the ice coyotes look to get a handle on it but
Dodie feeds it in front a chance for Lewis and
tight save still a scramble still loose lizard
taking over for gabrikov down low Lewis tipped
it just wide here's fiala who's been on that
puck here in the period and now England across to
fiallo who tipped It Wide I think right down the
back check that was Keller Spence Clayton Keller
former first round pick shot from the right side
by Brown is handled here's fiala quickly into
the Zone curling drag but he fanned on the shot
behind the goal it took a funny
hop winds up in front but the
king's third away valamaki to Jersey
feeds it down low Schmaltz to Keller
in too deep and he scores vented in
on Copley from behind the goal line
behind the net there's the bounce okay now
he clears it away from the immediate danger
but then the coyotes take over once twice
three times cross seam cross ice passes
now the end result is what is considered
a bad goal because where it comes from
Keller waits for the goaltender to go down get
up you can see right there the cop leads a little
bit off balance dementelli turns cross-size
pass deflected picked up Zucker dementelli
and out to the blue line where a shot is blocked
from velamaki now machilia drive and he scores
quick great shot by Matthias Michelli the power
play goal makes it two-nothing coyotes but Kelly
just finds himself away from it now what down he
does here the king's defenseman the rule of thumb
in this situation is to move to the inside
of the ice allow the goaltender to see it
and it all lost it's a great shot by Michelli
carried to Center Ice by Cooley across ice pass
to Gunther broken up Spence into the slot hands
it off campe with a shot Penny scores Adrian Cafe
taking the drop pass from Australian native
Jordan Spence to get the Kings on the board
and campe will do it as well at once and then
watch him square up he gets himself in a shooting
position played by Dodie we've got Dodie and Dowdy
out there thanks very much Todd in the middle
Crouch scores set up from the corner Austin Krauss
one times it 3-1 Arizona up the boards and watch
out quickly contact can't find it huge dad looking
he's waiting for it one touch pass one cut shot
a career high he's a big forward at 6-4 this is
his eighth season in Arizona he is the longest
tenured current coyote three to one coyotes
dancing Cooley scores what a goal by the youngster
Cooley comes right back follows up the Klaus goal
4-1 Arizona mistakes from young players look at
this I mentioned earlier that he's a dancer watch
the dance move right there and then gets himself
in a position when he spins the second time
he's in a perfect shooting position [Applause]
and he uses everything to hoist that puck quickly
to the top of the net moves in the middle to Cali
have a shot save rebound Dubois from behind the
goal line threw it in front it's cleared away now
Kelly have a chance or at least to know in a save
made and a whistle or kempe kempe had passed block
coyotes at full strength can't clear Piola scores
from the high slot might have been tipped in front
with fiala and kempe you have that opportunity
to keep pucks alive get into the zone you see
that stick on the ice it created a situation where
the coyotes could not get the loose Puck pressure
turn it over Gunther couldn't make a play and
now here is harvickson on left wing more more
to the net with a shot he scores
Trevor Moore was looking to pass
decided to shoot and here look
at the covering at you England comes out
once twice look at a moving screen again
more minor coyotes holding on to a one goal lead
up by pressure kobatar on a turnover picks it up
kobitar looking for a play cross ice one timer
by Roy black and band on campaign bouncing [__]
gabrikov threw it in front kobachar knocked
down to more for fiala to kempe Kings have a
power play can't pay Iran one man in shoots save
his maid no rebound nice effort by Adrian kempe
things are over four here's kempe with room
and opens up in the middle shoots save is made
looked up a lot of open ice fiala on the left
wing side centers tip just wide Dowdy back to
fiala kobachardo Dubois the one times it wide
the play was there under a minute to play 4-3
Arizona kobachar centers through the slot
Cafe's one-timer block Tempe recovers out
to Dowdy Dowdy for fiala fiala for kobitar
again and to fiallo for kobachar kobachar at
the goal line Center spinning arbitson deflects
on the draw and off the draw the puck bounces
for fiala but he's stripped by Schmaltz ahead to
Keller for Hayden empty net look and he'll score
gets into his hands there and it bounced a
couple of times and I was just mentioning make
sure things aren't clean let her the global
Series in Australia this weekend [Applause]
at Center Ice the puck in Skates of players
as the horn ends game one here in Melbourne
5-3 Arizona Cooley gets the first star of the
game [Applause] only game one of preseason both
teams salute the crowd here Rob labor Arena game
number one game number two coming up tomorrow
unofficially the shots 37-20 for LA but the
coyotes win the game by a score of five to three